inosuke just shoves it all into his
mouth but i'm not gonna
mother hello everybody it is me elise
and today i am making every single dish
from demon slayer kimetsu no iba or
demon slayer follows the story of
tanjiro his sister nesco and their
friends nitsu and enosuke as they travel
the world in search of the cure for the
demon curse
demon slayer is so popular and the movie
was
immaculate so of course i am going to
make every single dish
from this anime there's not too many but
there's just enough
so let's do it do you guys remember the
scene where tonji rose and itsu and
enosuke are led to that mansion and
there's that old lady who feeds them a
bunch of food and takes care of them and
you know
keeps trying to eat all the tempura that
is what i am making let's do it
alright so for the tempura i got my
eggplant
lotus fruit sweet potato zucchini
and of course our shrimps i made the
tempura batter by sifting some cake
flour
combining an egg some ice cold water
into a bowl and mixing it
and then adding the cake flour little by
little until it was all combined
okay so now that my batter is done my
vegetables are prepped and my shrimp is
shrimping
it is time to coat everything so we can
go fry it we're gonna coat them
in the flour and then put them into
our mixture here we're gonna bring it
over to the stove so we can fry it
i fried the vegetables first then the
shrimp i tried not to overcrowd the pan
and only cook them for about two to
three minutes
they came out so beautiful and crispy
all right
i have my tempura and it's smelling
so nice and so delicious i think i'm
gonna start with the zucchini
inosuke just shoves it all into his
mouth but i'm not gonna
i dropped my zucchini i'm still gonna
eat it
but i'm not gonna do that because i am
private
now of course the shrimp come on get
some shrimp
oh yeah yeah i gave up on the chopsticks
i'm gonna continue eating this oh yeah
now i'm going to make the bento box that
run goku was eating when he was on the
mugen train and couldn't stop saying how
delicious it was
for the bento box i cut some thin strips
of
steak some green onion and a regular
onion
and some firm tofu then i grilled those
up so nicely
oh yes and then it was time to put
everything together
i put some rice as the base and went
ahead and put on my grilled steak come
on come on
a little bit of tofu my green onions and
then of course
this is my friend the egg and a little
bit of dried seaweed and there it is
delicious delicious
i don't like tofu but
delicious all right i am going to finish
eating this because
rengoku ate like 15 so i have to
eat at least that amount next i'm going
to make the onigiri that tonjiro and his
friends were given when they set off on
their next mission
i got my rice here i've got some
seaweed and i've got of course the
umaboshi which is traditionally what
onigiri is stuffed with
but then i also have here a little tuna
mixture
to have a different flavor in the other
one hey how you doing let's grab a mound
of
rice and we're gonna just start forming
it into a triangle shape
i usually just push a little hole into
the center
umeboshi our pickled plum and we're
gonna put that right there
in the center another scoop of rice to
cover the top
i'm getting really good at shaping these
i feel like i do this so often
put it right on top and form the two
halves together
wonderful i got some strips of seaweed
here we're gonna wrap these
around each side and it's like a little
holy thing you know here they are my two
onigiri oh yes
let's give one of these a try
oh yeah i've heard you can buy this on
the street or you can just eat it as a
snack but i feel like with the amount of
rice that this is made out of
it's it's a pretty heavy snack right but
it's delicious
all right let's move to the next dish
remember the scene where tonjiro
literally scarfs down two bowls of udon
yeah i'm gonna make that so i started my
broth with
some dried shiitake mushrooms seaweed
fish flakes boiled that all up and got
myself a nice little broth going
i grated my japanese mountain yam the
texture is so
sloopy doopy oh it's so slimy
grated that up i also have
my udon noodles i fried my egg just a
little bit
cut my green onions and now it's time to
assemble
starting with soy sauce as a base to get
that salty flavor then i'm just pouring
in my udon noodles
then goes in the delicious broth oh yes
look at that color
then the japanese mountain yam wow wow
okay sunny side up egg come through then
the green onions and a little bit of
crispy dried seaweed
and a little bit of wasabi yes there it
is our udon
all right here it is the udon that
tanjuro
and nesco were eating omg
it smells really good just like udon
that you would get at like
a restaurant and i'm very curious about
this this this
mountain yam look at that texture
give this a little slurp
oh i surprised myself
tonderon knew what he was ordering when
he when he got this
i guess the mountain yam is more of a
texture thing than it is a flavor thing
because it's a very
very mild flavor but this is good i
enjoy this that was it
that was every single dish from demon
slayer hopefully
i'm pretty sure that was everything if i
missed something let me know but
that was a pretty fun challenge there
wasn't too many complicated things
and yeah it was great i don't know what
anime i'm going to do next but
definitely leave in the comments any
suggestions that you guys would like to
see
and yeah